Bien le bonjour chers camarades !
Aujourd'hui on va jouer à un jeu fait par des Français
Ils s'appellent TurfuStudio, ils m'ont envoyé leur jeu en exclusivité, je suis très content, merci à eux
Je vous présente MatchD. MatchDi, je sais pas comment ça se dit.
C'est un simulateur de Tinder, mais en français
On va jouer à un jeu en français, c'est historique, c'est génial.
Le but est de draguer une nana par messagerie jusqu'à la pécho
Comme le vrai Tinder
De nombreuses techniques sont possibles : lover, beauf, fragile, fan de Jul... pour débloquer les différentes fins.
Très bien ! Et bah c'est parti mec !
Ah ok, faut choisir ! Haha c'est génial !
Patricia, 30, assistante en cabinet dentaire. Ouais...
Diala, esthéticienne. Camille, mannequin grande taille.
Louise, 22, apprentie dresseuse d'ours.
Et bah voilà, putain, j'... J'ai toujours voulu trouver une apprentie dresseuse d'ours !
Eh mec, mec faut que je change absolument cette chaise, ça devient grave !
Clément, qui m'aide à faire les vidéos, me dit "Non, la change pas"
Mec, il faut que je la change ! Un jour je vais mourir, je vais me briser la nuque tu seras au chômage, Clément !
Ouaiiis, Louise !
Alors, comment séduire Louise ?
Elle écrit ! Elle écrit en première c'est bon signe ! *ding* "Salut !"
"Hello". "Wesh bb". "Ravi de faire votre connaissance gente dame". "Tu suces ?"
Heu, nan, nan nan, sucer en plus dans la dernière vidéo il y a déjà eu des... Bon
"Hello" ! La bonne réponse neutre ! En plus, moi je dis vraiment hello, en plus.
Voilà. P'tite info incroyable.
"Ca va ?"
"Envoie une dick pic". C'est bien ça ! *rire*
Et attention, est-ce que... "Casse-toi sale boloss". "Louise vient de vous bloquer"
Bah voilà, on voit que j'ai beaucoup expérimenté le vrai Tinder, ça se voit !
On va dire "Bien et toi ?". Voilà comme ça au moins on est serein
*Ding* "Très bien". Parfait, tu m'en vois ravi.
Oh merde, c'est à moi d'enchaîner là ! Ah elle m'a eu là ! Là elle m'a eu !
"Je peux avoir une photo de tes pieds steuplait ?" Attends ça se trouve elle kiffe ! Ca se trouve elle aime les pieds aussi !
*rire* Ah non ! "Louise vient de vous bloquer, vous attendez la photo de ses orteils pendant deux heures avant d'aller vous branler dans une chaussette en pleurant."
"Faites un point sur votre vie c'est urgent."
Oh je savais que ça passerait pas, ça
Je vais attendre qu'elle reparle. T'sais, ça c'est vraiment les mecs virils qui font ça,
qui arrivent à ne pas parler, qui laissent le temps.
"Bon alors, qu'est-ce que tu fais sur MatchD ?" Aaah, ça a marché !
"Je suis principalement là pour baiser des grosses biatch, et toi ?
On est franc ou on n'est pas franc, hein ! "Je suis là pour faire des rencontres, le reste on verra après"
Oh le mec quoi ! Le mec il est là genre "ouais j'veux juste rencontrer des gens, parler..." Espèce de mytho !
Tu veux pécho ! Tu veux tremper ton zizi ! ... Pardon.
Moi j'dirais on est franc : "je suis principalement là pour baiser des grosses biatch."
"Moi je suis là pour me taper un maximum de mecs ça tombe bien, ça te pose pas de problème ?"
"Heu non non pas du tout mdr" : non surtout pas... "Non mais on peut apprendre à se connaitre avant" : c'est bien ça, ça c'est bien ça.
*il lit le message de Louise*
Tu es folle ! Tu es juste folle.
"Alors on commence, niveau cinéma tu préfères quoi ?" *bruit de réflexion intense*
Oh putain, je fais le quiz et on se retrouve après pour voir si... si c'est la cata.
"Décidément, on est vraiment compatibles. Et musicalement ? C'est hyper important."
Putain les gars, c'est la dernière question, c'est la dernière question !! We can do it !
"J'écoute de tout sauf du metal, c'est pour les nazis" Pffff, lol. "J'écoute de tout sauf du rap c'est pour les racailles."
"J'écoute de tout, ce qui m'importe c'est les émotions que ça véhicule". C'est beau ça. Là je sens que hmm, il va se passer quelque chose avec Louise.
Voilà maintenant elle veut savoir ce que j'ai fait comme études...
Putain c'est un entretien d'embauche là c'est quoi là !
J'ai eu mon bac et je suis Youtubeur... Ok !? Et t'es mal placée pour me critiquer parce que t'es dresseuse d'ours meuf, hein.
Oh c'est bien de dire "je crois pas que le cursus fasse la personne". Ouais mais non ça c'est vraiment la phrase du mec qu'à... *rire* qu'à eu zéro diplôme !
"J'ai eu le brevet, le bac, je suis allé un peu à la fac." Vas-y c'est bien, ça.
"J'reviens je vais manger, d'ailleurs c'est quoi ton plat préféré ?" Putain elle me rend ouf...
"Un bon plat fait par ma petite femme quand je reviens du boulot" Oh c'est tellement macho !
"Ca dépend, j'adore cuisiner, donc je vais te dire un de mes petits plats faits avec amour"
"Tu es l'homme parfait ma parole. Et si je te dis que je suis végane, allergique au gluten et intolérante au lactose ?"
Tu es chiante. Tu es chiante ! "Je t'accepte telle que tu es. Moi même je suis allergique aux sales hippies bouffeuses de graines" *rire*
*rire* Ah c'est pas mal je m'y attendais pas ! Ça se voit que c'est fait par des mecs qui ont vingt piges et quelques, c'est drôle !
"J'accepte ta différence et j'essaye de te comprendre." *ton solennel* : Car aucun de nous deux n'a raison. Nous avons juste chacun un point de vue différent.
"Haha t'as des animaux de compagnie ? Je sais plus si on en a parlé"
Putain mais meuf mais... Là elle me scanne j'en ai marre !
Elle me scanne plus que quand à l'aéroport je passe aux rayons X quoi  !
Pas mal ça !
Bah les chats hein... "Je suis plutôt Team Chien". Merde !! Ah la première grosse erreur !
"J'espère que c'est pas trop un problème." Pas de problème, ils apprendront à se connaître, comme nous... *rire*
"T'as des hobbies dans la vie ?" Nan mais là par contre j'en peux plus. Nan mais je n'en peux plus !
Oh putain les amis ! Elle a posé dix-huit questions d'affilée je n'en peux plus !
Là elle dit : "Parfait, on continue un peu les questions ?"
Meuf, t'es folle. Et franchement, j'ai envie de te bloquer. J'ai vraiment envie de te bloquer.
"Pas de souci, ça me plaît ce petit jeu". Donc ça c'est la réponse qu'il faut mettre, on va pas se mytho.
"Tu veux pas plutôt on baise ?" Voilà, à un moment faut être franc. Nan mais voilà !
"Pourquoi pas, si tu réponds juste à deux questions, ok ?" Putain... *cri de ras-le-bol*
"Schopenhauer se place en héritier de qui ?"
Bon on va dire heu... Je sais pas mec, je sais pas.
On va dire que c'est l'héritier de Kant. Allez, c'est le seul que je connaissais.
"Les fans d'Hanouna se font appeler les...?" *rire* La meuf elle pose une question sur des philosophes et ensuite elle parle des fanzouzes, quoi... Putain !
Les fanzouzes. Allez, vas-y. Allez, allez on se met chaud !
"Ok, viens, maintenant." "Vous décrochez un RDV avec Louise."
"Le courant passe bien et elle vous propose de rentrer chez elle"
"Arrivé là-bas, vous vous sentez un peu chelou et vous lui demandez où sont les toilettes.
"Et en ressortant, vous constatez que la pièce entière... est tapissée de plastique."
"Elle vous attend, nue au milieu de la pièce, une hache à la main"
"Il lui faudra plus de deux mois pour vous manger en entier, mais c'est pas grave... Elle a un grand congélo.
"American psycho : vous finissez en kébab"
Mais naaaaan putain ! La dresseuse d'ours qui bouffe de l'humain, quoi... Putain...
Elle couche avec des ours et elle bouffe des humains, ça n'a pas de sens.
Très bien. Eh bien c'était la première fin. Très bien.
Alors on a une serveuse, une déscolarisée, une étudiante en lettres, une assistante en cabinet dentaire, un chef de projet junior,
Toi, non, tu m'as mangé donc je veux plus de toi !
Léa, 19 ans, étudiante en lettres ! Vamos.
"It's a match !" Wouh ! C'est parti.
"Salut !" "Ravi de faire votre connaissance gente dame"
Ah bah elle est étudiante en lettres hein ! A un moment il faut... Hein !"
"Ah tiens, un poète !" "Ton père est un voleur, il a pris les étoiles du ciel et les a mises dans tes yeux"
"Oui j'adore tout ce qui est poésie, Victor Hugo, Mylène Farmer, etc..." Allez on va mettre ça, c'est mieux.
"Bon alors qu'est-ce que tu fais sur Match ?" On va dire pareil : "je suis principalement là pour baiser des grosses biatch"
*rire* Cette réponse elle est incroyable !
"Moi je suis là pour me taper un maximum de mecs, ça tombe bien."
Ah, elle répond pareil que l'autre, qu'elle veut se taper un maximum de mecs ! Eh bah on dit "oh que non" avec la dic pic
"Ok je t'attends" "Vous décrochez un RDV avec Léa". Quoi ?!! *rire*
What the fuck mon gars, c'est allé beaucoup trop vite !
"Le courant passe bien". Range cette hache Léa !
"Arrivé là-bas vous vous sentez un peu chelou et vous lui demandez où sont les toilettes."
"Et en ressortant vous constatez que la pièce entière est tapissée de plastique. "
Les gars je crois qu'il y a un problème avec votre jeu... *rire*
Est-ce que Léa et Louise sont en fait la même fille ?
En fait je pense que la fin est liée à mes réponses. Et vu que là j'ai mis les mêmes réponses que tout à l'heure, bah la fin était la même, voilà.
Sauf que tout à l'heure j'ai dû répondre à 800 questions et que là j'ai juste envoyé une photo de ma bite !
Morale de l'histoire : envoyez toujours une photo de votre bite, dans le doute.
"Adèle, serveuse". Allez Adèle !
"Bon alors, tu fais quoi sur MatchD ?" "Je cherche le grand amour, la passion, je veux des enfants et vite !"
Ça, ça va lui plaire, ça. Ça va vraiment la mettre en confiance et elle va vraiment vouloir sortir avec moi, Adèle.
"Moi aussi, je cherche la plus belle des passions. C'est quoi pour toi ce qu'il y a de plus beau au monde ?"
"L'Amour avec un grand A." "La Vie avec un grand V". "Ton cul avec un gros string". *rire*
"L'Amour avec un grand A". On va se la jouer poète pendant cette game, c'est bien ça !"
"Oui ! Décris-moi pour toi la date parfaite."
"Bougies, pétales de roses, jazz et bon vin, pour te faire rêver."
"Champ de blé, bouteille de champagne et ciel étoilé, pour te faire voyager."
"Des putes et du Jul, pour te faire twerker !"... Pardon.
Bougies et pétales de roses, ça va lui plaire... On se la joue lover, on se la joue lover les gars !
"De mieux en mieux, j'ai envie de te rencontrer. Maintenant"
"J'accours, je vole, un signe de vous est un arc-en-ciel dans la grisaille automnale de mes nuits"
Ouais, ouais, on a vraiment répondu ça, ouais. Ouais, je sais, je suis choqué moi aussi.
"Parfait mon beau damoiseau." "Vous décrochez un RDV avec Adèle"
"Vous lui achetez un bouquet de fleurs, et quand elle arrive, vous lui lisez un poème que vous avez écrit en chemin."
"Elle fait demi-tour et s'enfuit. Vous rentrez chez vous tête basse et postez un odieux article misogyne sur votre blog."
"En disant que toutes ces putes ne vous méritent pas."
"Prenez un peu de recul, vous ne chopperez jamais avec cette attitude, mon petit vieux !"
"CANARD ! Coin coin coin."
Aaaah ! Bah voilà pourquoi on fait jamais les poètes ! Parce qu'après, tes potes ils te traitent de canard, voilà mesdames !
Allez vous plaindre à nos copains !
"Clara, déscolarisée". C'est la dernière, on va tout donner, "wesh bb !"
Ah on y va cash ! "Eh bah tu perds pas de temps, toi"
Ok, je lui ai dit que j'aimais que des films un peu ghetto, genre Le Parrain, Psychose, Apocalypse now...
"J'adore, même si en ce moment je regarde plutôt des séries, tu suis quoi, toi ?"
Alors niveau séries, on est plutôt Derrick, Louis la Brocante et Joséphine Ange Gardien.
"Clara s'est enfuie en courant" Et merde.
Des comédies, Modern Family, Community, Friends, tout ça... Bien sûr.
"Et musicalement ?" "J'écoute du JUL et toi ?"
"J'adore c'est quoi ton morceau préf ?" *rire*
C'est bon ça.
Wesh alors bien sûr, wesh alors !
"Et tu cabres comment ?" *rire*
"En Y" "Je... Je crois que je veux te voir, maintenant, sors le cross volé, cabre même si..."
"La roue est voilée ?"
"Viens à moi. Vite." "Vous décrochez un RDV avec Clara"
"Elle arbore un tee-shirt Jul. Vous tombez à genoux et la demandez en mariage directement."
"Vous vous enfuyez vers Marseille en scooter... Cabré, bien évidemment, en Y."
"AUTOTUNE. Vous cabrez même si la roue est voilée."
Et bah c'est une excellente fin pour mettre fin à cette vidéo !
Et voilà les gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo sur MatchD !
Merci à TurfuStudio de me l'avoir envoyé, c'était hyper rigolo, les gars, et puis ça me fait plaisir des petits jeux indés français comme ça.
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plu et à télécharger le jeu si vous voulez voir les autres fins,
j'en ai fait que quatre sur treize. Ca s'appelle MatchD, je crois que c'est aussi sur Android et iOS,
Voilà, on met bien TurfuStudio aujourd'hui, c'est la famille !
Je vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé, portez-vous bien, ciao tout le monde...
J'pars en Y frère !